a handover of power in costa rica
rodrigo chavez is presented the
presidential sash after running a
successful campaign as a political
maverick who promised to clean up a
broken system
a message he repeated at his
inauguration
[Applause]
it is time to leave behind the old
practices that the costa rican people
rightly fault us with there is no
difference between the ruling party and
the opposition if the political class
fails once again our country could fall
apart
the rise of the former world bank
official has surprised many he emerged
from the shadows to the presidency after
serving only eight months as finance
minister in the previous administration
he brought a populist streak to the
usually subdued costa rican presidential
campaign exploiting a growing resentment
against traditional parties and people's
worries of rising unemployment crime and
the cost of living
in costa rican politics we are now uh in
a new
area uh a terrible activity you know
high electoral volatility you know big
changes in terms of support
and also political parties are
weak
right
their electoral bases are small
since clinching victory though chavez
has shown a more traditionally
conservative side promising to keep
public finances solvent and reducing
expectations on immediate major
increases on social spending
observers say you will face an uphill
battle and an increasingly disillusioned
public his party will have only 10 of
costa rica's 57 congressional seats
meaning he will have to reach agreements
with the more traditional parties
there are two big questions
one is going to be able
to build a team
because these people don't know
each other
at all
and they are going to have to work
together so that that's a big question
and the other big question the the
biggest i would say
it's precisely that
the people who really voted for him
who wanted tabula rasa
what are they gonna do
because they won't have it
costa rica has long been recognized as
central america's most stable country
applauded for its environmental and
moderate economic policies but many
believe that if chavez fails his
presidency could trigger a more unstable
and turbulent time for this country
alessandro rampiti al jazeera